Ready to suit up, Keanu?
During this year's San Diego Comic-Con, filmmaker
and comic book geek Kevin Smith had a chance
to chat with Avengers: Endgame directors Joe
and Anthony Russo and the three of them had
a little chat about Keanu Reeves' place in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
Speculation over Reeves joining the MCU has
recently grown to a fever pitch.
The actor's career has been enjoying a stellar
resurgence thanks in large part to the highly
successful John Wick franchise, and he and
the MCU seem like a match made in Hollywood
heaven.
"Yeah, I'm thinking I'm back."
Marvel Studios head honcho Kevin Feige recently
threw fuel on the rumor fire by suggesting
that Reeves has been considered for virtually
every movie Marvel has ever made, and that
the only reason he hasn't shown up so far
is that they simply haven't found the right
part for him.
If it were up to Smith and the Russo brothers,
however, Reeves would be donning a white bodysuit,
cape, and cowl and stepping into the role
of Marc Spector, otherwise known as Moon Knight.
During their comic-con interview, Smith posed
a simple question to the Russo brothers: who
would they like to see Reeves play in the
MCU?
Much hemming and hawing ensued, with the Russos
admitting that the choices were pretty much
limitless, before Smith offered up Moon Knight
as his pick prompting Joe Russo to reply:
"Right, that's a good call."
Just like Keanu, it seems to be more a matter
of when, not if, Moon Knight will eventually
appear in the MCU.
Considered by some to be Marvel's answer to
Batman, Marc Spector is a one-time mercenary
who suffers from dissociative identity disorder.
On assignment in Egypt, he had a transformative
experience when his life was spared by the
ancient god Khonshu.
In return, he agreed to serve Khonshu on Earth.
With the help of his right-hand man Frenchie
and his significant other Marlene, Spector
uses his considerable fortune to equip himself
as the costumed vigilante Moon Knight, becoming
the bane of the New York City criminal underworld.
"I, the moon's knight of vengeance, must carry
out your luminous will.”
“Ah… are you seriously talking to the
moon?
As in, the cow jumped over?"
The character has long been a favorite of
Marvel comics fans, and it was suggested early
and often that he would lend himself well
to a Netflix series a notion that sadly became
moot when Marvel Television ended its relationship
with the streaming service in 2019.
As recently as last year, however, Feige remarked
that Moon Knight was one of the characters
being eyed for a potential MCU solo feature
but there was no mention of the character
during the recent reveal of Marvel's Phase
4 slate at Comic-Con, meaning that any such
project isn't likely to come to fruition for
at least a few years.
Ultimately, this makes it almost certain that,
when Marc Spector finally shows up in the
MCU, he won't be portrayed by Reeves.
Sure, the star has proven his action skills
with the John Wick series, but when it comes
to casting, Marvel is in the midst of something
of a youth movement.
The studio famously likes to sign its featured
players to multiple-picture deals stretching
over several years which is part of the reason
why, for example, Feige has stated his intention
to go younger for the actors he will eventually
cast as the X-Men.
And since Endgame will likely be the final
Marvel movie to be directed by Joe and Anthony
Russo, the ace filmmakers basically have no
horse in the race.
As cool as it would be to see Reeves don Moon
Knight's cowl, it seems unlikely that the
54-year old actor would be able to remain
in the role for the five to 10 years that
Marvel would demand of him.
Of course, it goes without saying that Feige
and his team are very, very good at their
jobs.
And when Marvel finally announces Reeves's
role in the MCU, you can bet your bottom dollar
that it'll prove to be the perfect match.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.